al Sharpton takes center stage at the
George Floyd Memorial a New York Times
editor urges targeting of those who
disagree with the local police and the
governor of Kentucky announces illegal
racial reparations I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show today's show is
sponsored by expressvpn protect your
data from prying eyes at expressvpn
dot-com slash Ben all righty so
everything is canceled guys it's very
exciting we've reached a new moment in
America and that is everyone who has
ever said anything that the woke police
don't like is canceled they will lose
their jobs they'll lose no career no
this had been on the wave for a while
we've been saying this for a long time
this sort of attitude that is pervasive
throughout the media that true
journalism can be found in digging up
people's 12 year old 15 year old 20 year
old tweets and then shaming them into
giving up their jobs or leaving their
positions unless they have the proper
world politics if you have the proper
world politics you get to keep your jobs
if you're Jimmy Kimmel and you are the
woke Pope of late-night TV then you
absolutely get to dress in blackface as
Karl Malone and keep your job if you're
Jimmy Fallon and you have elde the knee
to the politically correct police then
you get to dress up as Crick Rock a
Chris Rock back in 2000 apologize and
everything is okay
if however you aren't any of those
things then your wife has to apologize
like drew brees your second cousin from
Duluth has to apologize and you may not
be able to keep your job at all and this
is the new pattern in American public
life so if your politics are correct
then you get to basically say whatever
you want historically and if we find
something kind of uncomfortable well
then you know we'll sort of brush it off
you're out nor them and you dress up in
a KKK outfit in the 1980s well then
you're totally fine I've been consistent
on this which is people sin people are
sinful people do things that are bad in
their lives and they should apologize to
people to whom they have sinned and they
should do restitution to people against
whom they have sinned people make bad
comments people should apologize for
those bad comments a bad comment is not
the same thing as doing something deeply
damaging to another human being right an
assault is not the same thing as saying
something bad to someone a bad joke is
not the same thing as firing someone
over over race but we don't abide by any
and by the way I hold to those standards
right left and centre I've defended
people on the Left who have said stuff
that is deeply offensive and wrong to
take a perfect example Sarah Rao now
works at the New York Times when she was
first hired by the New York Times people
resurfaced old tweets
where she was joking about how white
people's opinions suck and stereotypical
white people and all this kind of stuff
and I said okay well I think that those
comments are pretty bad but the New York
Times knew what they had when they hired
her and so she shouldn't lose her job
over anything like that because guess
what in a society with a lot of opinions
and a lot of diversity you're gonna have
to tolerate some opinions you don't like
and even some nastiness you're gonna
have to tolerate all that if you want to
live together because it turns out
people are sinful and say nasty and
terrible things to one another all the
time and that is not the same thing as
ruining somebody's life that is not the
same thing as creating systems from
oppression that is not the same thing by
any stretch of the imagination now if
you're gonna hold true to the standard
that the left is currently setting up
which is that if you've said something
that targets another group or you've
said something offensive or racially
insensitive then your life is over well
then that should be evenly applied
across the spectrum and then no one gets
to work because as we will see the way
that this works is that the people who
are deemed okay by the woke police get
away with anything and everything that
could possibly want to say including
some of the worst racial slurs
imaginable but if you do not side with
the woke police on their decision-making
about policy or about America being a
systemically racist and evil country and
about you bearing guilt for the things
that ancestors of yours or non ancestors
of yours did well then you are part of
the problem and we will use every
indicator that you once told the bad
joke is an indicator that you are a
direct ideological descendant of
slaveholders
even if you are it's a natural descent
enough slaveholders that is the way this
will work so you just have to be on the
right side in other words there are a
lot of people on the Left today who are
saying this is the me to moment with
regard to racism it's the me to moment
with regard to racism well if it is then
it's gonna end just like meat eat meat
use it with a whimper not a bang it's
gonna end the moment that the left
realizes that they can't uphold their
own standards and when people expect
them to uphold their own standards
they're just going to shy away from it
because we know they're not going to do
that we know that they want Ralph
Northam to keep this job we know that
they're not interested in ousting
IceCube for being an anti-semite we know
that they're not interested in going
after LeBron James for his anti-semitic
Instagram comments a year and a half ago
we know they're not interested in going
after al Sharpton for being the worst
race baiter of the last 50 years we know
all of that and so what that means is
that people are going to see right
through this and they're gonna say okay
this is just a politically driven hit
job against people you don't like anyway
right that is mostly what this is and
that's not an excuse for people making
bad comments you should apologize and
then we should all move on with our
lives that is not an excuse
for a bad old tweet people do apologize
and they move on with their lives but
that is not what is happening right now
right now what we are watching is a seek
and Destroy mission against history
people trying to tear down statues of
Lincoln and Churchill not just statues
of Confederate slaveholders we are
seeing people attempting to wipe away
Western history we are seeing people
attempt to wipe away Western philosophy
rights themselves are apparently an
exercise of hierarchical power we are
seeing people attempt to wipe away and
erase aspects of history that are good
as we will see Hattie McDaniels the
first black Academy Award winner has now
been wiped away from history according
to HBO max because the movie in which
she started gone with the wind is now
perceived as wrong on slavery and there
are a lot of problems we've gone with
the wind on slavery but guess what that
is a classic movie it's a great movie
you can show that movie to people and
then say here are all the things that
are wrong with it but we're not gonna do
that we're just gonna wipe away the
history and we're gonna create a new
world the first the first move toward
creating a new world is destroying the
old one and that is what we're watching
in real time and anybody who says wait a
second some things about this world are
pretty damn good those people are now
the targets whereas if you are trying to
tear down the old world you can say
whatever the hell you want about anybody
at any time it does not matter we're
gonna get to this in just one second
because it's a pretty ugly world we're
about to create tearing tearing down the
temple around the ears of the
Philistines here is not what is
happening instead you're just tearing
down the temples of Western civilization
in the name of a better world and the
better world ain't coming because you've
proposed no policies that make this
world better we're gonna get to this in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that personal finance these
days is incredibly important a lot is up
in the air
right now especially when it comes to
our personal finances you shouldn't let
your personal finances get you down
simplify is here to help start healthier
financial habits achieve your long-term
goals with simplified by quicken so
here's what it is it's a financial app
and it tracks not just what you have
going on your bank account right now but
it hopes you have forecast what is
coming down the pike so you can make
sure that you have enough money in your
bank account going forward you can say
goodbye to surprise charges from
subscriptions you forgot you signed up
for simplify makes it easy to monitor
all your spending so you're never in the
dark other financial apps primarily
track what's already happened in the
past but again if you're looking to the
future that's not what you need you
don't need to know what you spent last
month you need to know what you are
expected to spend at this month and
whether you got the money
to cover it you can get personalized
tips and insights to help develop
healthy long-term finance
habits and stay on top of your finances
now and in the future as somebody who
likes to be right on top of their
financial picture at all times simplify
is indispensable
other financial apps feel like they
guilt you like for not meeting your
goals but simplify isn't gonna overwhelm
you
with every dollar you're off by instead
it's just gonna give you the information
that you need start your free 30-day
trial if simplify today when you
download the app or visit simplify
money.com
slash Shapiro that is si m PL IFI
simplify with an eye at the end
money.com slash Shapiro and take control
of technology to help you get control of
your spending it is a must in today's
environment simplify money.com
slash capiro go check them out right now
okay so how can we tell that a double
standard is underway or a triple
standard or a quadruple standard is
underway when it comes to who must be
ousted from places of public approval
well we know this because al Sharpton
was the keynote speaker at the memorial
for George Floyd now they're a bunch of
speakers at Memorial for George Floyd
who are great seriously Kyle Theater
came was great we had members of the
George Floyd family who were great we
had local pastors were great
now Sharpton's a grifter how Sharpton's
race baiter Al Sharpton's a terrible
human being al Sharpton has spent years
doing everything from inciting violence
being involved in the incitement of not
one but two riots the Crown Heights riot
in 1991 that ended with the death of an
Orthodox Jew Yankel Rosenbaum to
inciting a an arson at a at a at a
district called the Freddie's fashion
Mart and as a small shop that ended up
killing with actually minority people
now Sharpton is spent years grifting he
literally made up a rape case against a
DA that did not exist with tamanho
Brawley
he spent years saying the worst things
imaginable about Jews about white people
he's just garbage he's a garbage human
being al Sharpton and he has made his
career basically by going around and
threatening companies and saying if you
refuse to give a donation to my group
then I'm just gonna call you racist we
did this with Macy's most memorably
where he went to Macy's he accused them
of profiling black shoppers and then he
said but if you give a donation I will
quiet down about all that that's
essentially what he did hey I'm just
gonna read you some of Reverend Al
Sharpton's racist statements okay these
are the things that Al Sharpton has said
in the past that guy has Show on MSNBC
and he spoke at George Floyd's Memorial
where he was apparently the gateway to a
new world which is pretty incredible he
said quote white folks was
in the caves while we blacks was
building empires we built pyramids
before Donald Trump ever knew what
architecture was we taught philosophy
and astrology and mathematics before
Socrates and then Greek homos ever got
around to it direct quote from al
Sharpton al Sharpton so if some cracker
come and tell you well my mother and
father blood go back to the Mayflower
you better hold your pocket then ain't
nothing to be proud of that means their
forefathers was crooks if the Jews want
to get it on tell them to pin their
yarmulkes back and come over to my house
he also called Jews diamond merchants
during the Freddie's fashion Mart
situation this guy is being trotted out
as the as the leader of the new America
that is going to be built in the wake of
the old racist systemically racist
America nobody's made a bigger career
off of calling America racist than Al
Sharpton without actually accomplishing
anything and accomplishing his chief
goal of making people in America feel
victimized when in fact the American
system is incredibly free if you want to
succeed in America work hard there's
nobody sitting there saying we want to
stop you seriously this notion that
there are people who are sitting up
nights trying to figure out how to stop
you is insane but the al Sharpton
perspective on the world has filtered
throughout American society perfect
example there's a guy named Meek Mill
Meek Mill is a very very wealthy rapper
okay how wealthy well here's what he
tweeted yesterday and this is pretty
indicative of one of the big problems in
the country maybe the biggest problem in
the country is the belief that success
is out of reach unless you reject the
American system so Meek Mill tweeted
quote I've never believed in the
American system I dropped out of school
in the tenth grade and made millions at
twenty-two the way they broke things
down to me didn't really fit my life as
a black kid from poverty so I took the
risk of chasing my own dreams not the
American dream that is the American
dream you dropped out of high school and
now you made millions at 22 and somehow
that's an indication that America is
deeply racist and wanted to keep you
down I'm gonna need some better evidence
than that dude but when you keep
promulgating the narrative that black
people all over the United States are
being kept down by the man that is that
is a negative narrative it doesn't help
people it is it is the least inspiring
message I could possibly think of
truthfully and it's being parodied by
everybody from Al Sharpton to Michelle
Obama Michelle Obama spoke to black
graduates two days ago and suggested
that no matter how hard you work there
are people who are trying to create
institutions of power to keep you down
this is a lie
it is a lie what are the institutions of
power that are trying to keep black
people
when they are trying to do the right
thing where are those institutions of
power how do we target them together but
those are not the conversations that are
being had instead the conversations that
are being had are pure vague
conversations about vague American
racial impurity and evil unrighteous
issues least you don't have to pose a
policy solution or even an inspiring
message for people who are trying to
make their way in the world all you have
to do is yell at people in power and
proclaim that they are racist so al
Sharpton spent his time at George
Floyd's Memorial ripping president Trump
and suggesting there was wickedness in
high places which again it seems to me
that if you're going to list all the
people who have done things that that
harmed
George Floyd President Trump is not
particularly on this list but this is
where Al Sharpton spends his time doing
again why this race-baiting
grifter was the keynote speaker at this
thing is beyond me if you could hardly
pick a worse example of a person to lead
a movement on behalf of racial justice
than the disgusting al Sharpton
here he was yesterday we are not
fighting some disconnected incidents we
are fighting an institutional systemic
problem that has been allowed to
permeate since we were brought to these
shores and we are fighting wickedness in
high places and wickedness in high
places meaning President Trump then on
the back of George Floyd's death
President Trump has to go weird because
I don't remember al Sharpton talking
about wickedness in high places during
Ferguson he was very involved in
Ferguson and and in Baltimore so really
it only applies to one side when
something bad happens in America the
system is to blame if Barack Obama is
not president is basically the message
you get from Al Sharpton now Sharpton
also spent some time ripping Roger
Goodell which makes perfect sense
because George Floyd played in the NFL
except for how he didn't play in the NFL
and this has nothing to do with Roger
Goodell but Roger Goodell must be made
to pay the price because Roger Goodell
was against people kneeling for the
American flag in the national anthem
which by the way was an 80/20
proposition before President Trump
started speaking about it most Americans
do not believe that the American flag
represents evil and white supremacy and
racism most
Americans don't believe that and they
don't believe that kneeling for the
American flag or the national anthem is
a good way to show that you oppose
police brutality because it suggests
that the American flag is about police
brutality which it is not but it was
very important than at George Floyd's
Memorial he grifter al Sharpton talked
about Roger Goodell and how he needs to
give Colin Kaepernick a job back oh it's
nice to see some people change their
mind Kenny the NFL said yeah maybe we
was wrong the football players maybe
they did have the right to peacefully
protest don't come with some empty
apology take a man's livelihood strip a
man down of his talents and four years
later when the whole world is marching
the all of a sudden you go into a face
time talking about you sorry okay so now
Roger Goodell must be made to kneel by
the way they're actually talking about
the possibility of Roger Goodell
kneeling for the national anthem in the
upcoming season that he's gonna come out
and fully pander and just kneel
first of all Colin Kaepernick was going
out on the practice field with socks
that showed cops as pigs Colin
Kaepernick has led an incredibly wealthy
an opportunity filled life in the United
States the kind of place where you can
earn a million dollars for kneeling in a
Nike commercial to pander politically
but Roger Goodell is the bad guy by the
way he was a backup quarterback for the
49ers if he wants his old job back I
suppose we can make him backup
quarterback for the 49ers again because
that's what he was listen first of all
let me just say that if I were an NFL
owner I would give Kaepernick a job I
would he's I think to excel tickets I
think it's all tickets because either he
plays great in which case he becomes
sort of the player that half the country
loves and half the country loves to hate
or he gets completely destroyed first
day on the job and gets sacked because
he doesn't know how to read a passing
route which was the big rap on
Kaepernick and then everybody who
doesn't like him cheers and everybody
who loves him and recognizes that he
wasn't that great a player in the first
place in all this but using the memorial
service for a man who died of police
brutality in order to in order to
promote Colin Kaepernick's job
opportunities is pretty astonishing by
the way Colin Kaepernick just last year
was given a workout by a bunch of teams
and here
fuse to abide by the rules of the
workout because he's posing because it's
all poser stuff so you have al sharpton
out there also you have Joe Biden Joe
Biden with his wonderful history on race
as everybody has noted and I'm old
enough to remember when Kamala Harris
was suggesting that Joe Biden was a
racist because he opposed forced busing
and because he had talked kindly about
segregation of senators and because he
back in 1994 crime reform bill I'm old
enough to remember when Joe Biden was
the bad guy but now Joe Biden is the
good guy why because he's a Democratic
nominee so he shows up at George Floyd's
Memorial as well again we're gonna
forget about all the things that Joe
Biden has ever done or said because Joe
Biden holds the correct the correct
politics that's the way that all of this
works day we're gonna get to Joe Biden
who is calling for change the man was
elected to Congress to the Senate in
1972 in 1972 he has been in elected
office in the United States since 12
years before I was born but now is the
time for change guys now is the time for
change we're gonna get to Joe Biden in
his hypocritical bullcrap in just one
second but first let us talk about
nutrition so I know that this pandemic
has been an awful time for people
attempting to lose weight you can't go
to the gym it's been really rough for a
lot of folks but I have lost weight
during this Penda but that's not I'm not
saying that to brag on myself I am
saying that because I know how to do
this and the way you do this is you use
new Newman's great it is a habit
changing solution so much of losing
weight and getting in shape really isn't
even about your exercise level it's more
about what you put in your body what are
the kind of things that you eat well
moom helps you take control of all of
your habits to have a changing solution
that helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses no food is good or
bad or off limits noon teaches
moderation can be used in conjunction
with many pre-existing popular diets if
you want newm doesn't tell you what to
do and what not to do instead it teaches
you how to look inside your own mind and
make better decisions for yourself new
has one of the biggest most accurate
food databases available it lets you
track meal habits visualize portion
sizes and see calorie density at a
glance you're human so if you go off
track there's no shaming just tips to
help you get back on track
tomorrow it's really great you can chat
with a goal specialist and the Newman
community say get and give help to
people who are going through the same
thing it really does change how you
think about nutrition in a serious way
and that's what you really need in order
to lose the weight and get healthier you
don't have to change it all in one day
small steps make big progress sign up
for your trial today at Numa that's n oo
m.com / Shapiro again new
calm / appear to start that trial today
I've got my parents using it to 1000m
calm / up your own oom dot-com / Shapiro
go check them out right now ok so it
wasn't just a LARP ttan grifting it was
also Joe Biden drifting so Joe Biden who
again has been in the United States
Senate since he was thirty years old
who's elected at 29 he is now 1237 years
old now is the time for Joe Biden to
talk about changes now is the time for a
tional justice ah Joe Biden I see you've
arrived at the party
you should probably speak at this
memorial because of all of the amazing
work you've done yeah mmm here's Joe
Biden speaking from his basement George
Bligh's memorial we cannot leave this
moment thinking we can once again turn
away from racism it's things that are
very soul from systemic abuse that still
plagues American life now it's the time
the purpose the season to listen and
heal now is the time for racial justice
that's the is we must give to our
children when they ask why because when
there is justice for George Floyd we
will truly be on our way to racial
justice in America okay I don't even
know what he means
do you know what he means when he says
racial justice that's a pretty that's a
pretty big phrase what is racial justice
means see to me anytime you had a
modifier before justice you're doing
something wrong there's no such thing as
social justice
there's just justice justice is the idea
that you get what you deserve right
George Floyd didn't deserve to die so he
was treated with injustice racial
justice is the idea that you by dint of
your race are deserving of something I
don't think you by dint of your race are
deserving of anything either good or bad
because I don't think you control your
race I think the idea of of
quote-unquote racial justice that idea
is is patently absurd on its face simply
because the the idea that you again
ought to be given something solely on
the basis of race is silly just like
social justice is silly there's only
individual justice
George Floyd deserved individual justice
no one deserves racial justice people
deserve individual justice they deserve
what they deserve they deserve every
opportunity
it is her freedom it is sort of Liberty
they deserve to be treated as individual
human beings because you're not just a
member of a racial group you're an
individual so I don't know what your
Biden means by that it's a
that sounds nice because anytime you say
justice and then add anything before it
it sounds nice but that but unless
you're going to unpack that phrase it is
a it is a meaningless mush phrase and
again I wonder if if people in that
crowd knew that what he was talking
about was adding more funding for police
whether they would be on board with his
conception of racial justice because
that is what Joe Biden has said at this
point and some me again
justice justice justice is what is
deserved everybody should have justice
but any time you had a modifier in front
of justice you have now moved away from
the world of justice and towards
something that is less just and so
speaking of things that are not just we
are now moving into the me2 era for
racism is the is the new declaration
what this means is not that we are going
to identify instances of you doing
something bad to another human being we
are going to dig up instances of things
that do not meet with the approval of
the world police and then we are going
to ruin your life over them and this is
being egged on by our journalistic by
our journalistic betters very exciting
stuff you know the the business of
journalism becomes incredibly easy when
all you have to do is search somebody's
old tweets the business of journalism
usually that involves you know tracking
down actual stories but now journalism
is basically you find a Yale freshman
and then you go back into her Facebook
posts and you find something that's
racially insensitive and then you ruin
her and this is making the world a
better place so there is a girl I'm
gonna say girl cuz young woman who goes
to Yale her name is Amanda Rose
apparently and she's I believe 18 years
old there's a woman named Skye Jackson
who I've never heard of before but she's
been going around on Twitter basically
trying to uncover people's bad old posts
I don't know who this person is but she
decided that she was going to go after
this this this person who is just a gay
lad matiee or post that was that was put
out what ten years ago five years ago
years ago that and for which she has
already apologized apparently and it's a
it's a an ugly post about when she I
think it's fun when she was fifteen is
the idea here in which she uses the
n-word yes that's very bad that's bad
should she have her life ruined over
that I'm gonna go no on that she was
fifteen years old this is the new
standard that if you say something when
you're fifteen years old we're gonna
ruin you there in a lot of a lot of
people whose lives are but we under
and that that is not the actual standard
here right that's not the actual
standard at all because if you're ice
cube and you put out black Hebrew
Israelite propaganda on your Twitter
feed and if you put out like actual
queuing on anti-semitism you're totally
fine so Ice Cube has 5.3 million Twitter
followers put out an openly anti-semitic
picture yesterday it's a picture of a
bunch of old Jewish men sitting over a
Monopoly board that is built on the back
of brown people and he says eff the new
normal until they fix the old normal has
Ice Cube faced any blowback is gonna
lose any jobs over this of course not
he's a hero of the Republic Ice Cube so
in other words the only people who are
to be targeted here our people who have
the wrong skin color or who don't
sufficiently bow to the world crowd and
by the way even if you batter the world
crowd it's not enough because then the
next man is okay so what have you done
for us lately that is the next move and
this New York Times editor makes this
completely clear her name is Aisha
Harris she's an op-ed staff editor and
writer there's a piece today it is one
of the most immoral pieces I have ever
seen in print is called this you it
definitely is and it's all about calling
people out for their sins of the past
but it's not really about atonement it's
not really about making the world a
better place what it really is about is
shaming you into doing things that we
want you to do with the threat of your
career that's really what this is about
this is why you have Jimmy Fallon on
late-night TV apologizing for his cruel
racism from 2001 didn't bother a damn
person back in 2000 because it's about
shaming him into doing a thing now
that's really what this is about we're
gonna get to this in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
right now pretty bad time to go to an
autoparts store in fact as it turns out
pretty much every time you go to an
autoparts store is a bad time to go to
an autoparts store because you're
probably overpaying for the parts
instead you should be using the glories
of the interweb Rock Auto comm is much
easier than walking into a store and
someone's demanding quick answers to
things like is your Odyssey and LX or
Annie X and then they just have to order
the part online anyway or they give you
a generic package overpriced instead go
to Rock Auto calm they always offer the
lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like the airline's do why
would you spend up to twice as much for
the same parts that's actually happening
very often you're paying way too much
when you go to an autoparts store
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto embody parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
the same
for professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why spend up to twice as much before the
same parts the rockauto.com catalog is
unique it is remarkably easy to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brands specifications and prices you
prefer amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need check them out at rockauto.com
again rockauto.com see all the parts
available for your car or truck and
right Shapiro's and there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
say ok so back to this
I think morally evil column from Aisha
Harris over the New York Times this you
it definitely is the Twitter meme of the
moment is all about accountability no
it's not it's not about accountability
it's not about accountability in the
slightest it's not consistently applied
it only applies to one side of the
political aisle if you are not a member
of the woken issue yet then you must you
must pay you must kneel and if you don't
kneel you must be destroyed and if you
do kneel you must be destroyed because
there's no absolution once you apologize
to the Twitter woke mob there there is
no recovery there is no world in which
you come back from that once you
apologize to the Twitter milk mob they
come for your head so according to Aisha
Harris this is all good
she says this you brutally crisp and
blatantly rhetorical the phrase has
become a catch-all representing the
internet currency of receipts forcing
bandwagon participants to confront
things they might have said or done that
seemingly contradict their newfound
commitment to the cause so in other
words what she is saying is that this
you is supposed to be directed
specifically at people who are
signalling support for your cause so if
you put up a black square on blackout
Tuesday or whatever that thing was and
then you have an old post that is
racially insensitive we say this you
because you have not shown your
commitment you are a hypocrite and if
you say well I apologize for that but I
actually do believe black lives matter
they say no you obviously didn't believe
that what are you gonna give me today
what are you gonna do for me today does
this sound like a way to make a better
world does this sound like a way to
encourage people to be better or does it
sound like a way to keep people silent
and a way for people to basically resent
you secretly which is exactly what is
going to happen or a way to eventually
cast enough people outside the Overton
Window that they constitute a majority
of American society because it turns out
that virtually everybody has said a bad
thing online at some point or another
but according to Aisha Harris this is
making the world a better place one
Twitter mobbing at a time these Twitter
mobs are good Twitter moms are good what
are her examples of a Twitter mob being
good the NFL player drew brees for
instance part
dissipated in the thoroughly muddled but
hugely popular social media campaign
blackout Tuesday tweeting a link to his
Instagram page where he posted a black
square to express solidarity with black
people a short and sweet this you was
waiting for him in the form of the users
retweet accompanied by a photo of a
smiling mr. breeze alongside President
Trump and Melania Trump wow wow owned
owned drew brees you mean you took a you
took a picture with the President of the
United States and the first lady how
dare you obviously you're racist and you
don't care about black wives if you took
a picture with President Trump and
Melania Trump obviously also since Aisha
Harris he's very bad because he was a
vocal critic of football players
kneeling to protest police brutality
during the national anthem obviously
he's very bad so we have to vist you him
by the way I've gotten a lot of this too
so for example I'll say something about
how police brutality is bad and George
Floyd never should have died and
somebody will tweet out a picture of me
with Steve King from five years ago
neglecting to mention that I'm one of
the chief reasons that Steve King is no
longer sitting in Congress that I was
the first major commentator suggest you
should be ejected from Congress after
his white supremacist comments went
around and then I maxed out to his
opponent Kevin Feenstra on the first day
of the controversy right that none of
that ever happens nobody talks about
Drew Brees giving five million dollars
to the people of Louisiana who are
disproportionately black on a
demographic basis ok but according to
Aisha Harris all of this is very good
the Baltimore Police Department's we did
photos of its officers kneeling with
protesters this you someone retweeted
with a screenshot of a New York Times
article featuring the mug shots of the
Baltimore officers involved in the
arrest of Freddie gray this you Mark
Wahlberg this you Justin Bieber this you
Disney oh well that that obviously is
making the world a much better place
clearly a much better place so what does
this mean it means intimidation this is
an intimidation tactic directed
specifically at you give us what we want
or we're going to do this to you and if
you if you have said something bad in
the past then you have to give us triple
what we want it's it's basically a
ransom note this you is a ransom note it
is give us what we want and continue
giving us what we want forever and
doesn't matter if you apologize that
doesn't matter one iota because if you
think that people are going to just
forgive drew brees for the great sin of
having said that he doesn't like
kneeling for the American flag you would
be wrong but according to Aisha Harris
it's delectable it's satisfying it's a
message a message for the moment in
which combating anti-blackness is the
thing to do
anti racist literature lists are being
shared far and wide inboxes are washing
there and carefully worded very special
emails from businesses espousing key
phrases like racial disparities and we
pledge to do better protests from city
to city and country to country have
carried on for many days now featuring
Penn Affleck and show a little sign of
slowing anytime soon this you captures
the sense among some that for all the
attention given and demonstrating and
donating that has occurred in the past
two weeks
not much has changed yet it feels like
this is lip service everyone is cool
doing it it's finally safe for them to
do two it highlights the hypocrisy the
disconnect between actions and words
that's the power a detailed tweet
revealing how a star who just announced
black lives matter also has a history of
mistreating her black colleagues is
juicy to read but of this you retweet
from a random user is like a simple
alley-oop it just hits differently it's
a way to keep people in organizations in
check and nudge them or nudge them to
work harder to receive their cookies to
make it clear this won't be easy for
them because it has never been easy for
black people ah there it is so you may
never have actually done it racist thing
you may have said something racially
insensitive on Twitter ones but you
don't get your cookie namely we're not
going to leave you alone we're gonna
hound you and harass you until you do
what we want because you said something
ten years ago we uncovered on Twitter
making the world a better place one
Twitter mobbing at a time really really
well done The Huffington Post mirrors
this message today they have a piece by
Emily Peck called the me to style
reckoning for racism has begun well if
you are going to say that it the meets
you style reckoning for racism has begun
remember how me two ended again with a
whimper when it turns out and nobody on
the Left wanted to be held accountable
for accusations of sexual harassment as
long as you're on the Left were let off
scot-free and eventually the American
people said you know what forget it
you're gonna have to show actual
evidence of people acting in evil ways
to women and we're not we're just not
gonna go along with the basic premise
that anyone who has ever sinned must be
destroyed by the mob I mean this is
Salem witch trial kind of stuff that is
happening right now and give you some
examples it's it's a minute because this
is the way that it works you said
something that was racially incentive
are you a racist or are you not well if
you're a witch and you'll sink if you're
a witch then you'll float either so
either you sink by apologizing right in
which case you're not a witch by your
dad or you float because you are a witch
in which case we burn you that is the
way that the Twitter mob is working
these days I'm going to give you a bunch
of examples because this is the
the culture cannot withstand us the
culture simply cannot withstand this
there we will break down into two
separate cultural camps and that is
what's going to happen because when you
remove every TV show that portrays cops
decently when you remove Gone with the
Wind from HBO max when you decide that
you're going to have every arts director
fired who has ever been nice to the
police when you've decided that every
editorial page editor who has ever said
something you don't like that is not
even race it's just stuff you don't like
has to be quote unquote racism the out
of office then all you're going to do is
just set up an alternative currency and
that's what's going to happen in the
night sights can make the world worse we
should be unified this is the most
unifying moment ever everyone hates
police brutality everyone hates racism
but there's a whole side of the
political aisle that cannot get done
what it wants to get done unless it
castigates at least half the country as
systemically in brutally racist if you
want to tear down the system it does not
serve your interests to mention that
America is actually a wonderful country
that has fought against racism
particularly over the last 50 years and
then the vast majority of Americans do
care about black lives and do care about
police brutality if you mention that it
cuts against your actual agenda which is
to destroy all the institutions of the
country so instead we're going to call
out every instance and magnify every
instance and pretend that that is
indicative of broader American racism
every singular instance of white on
black racism is going to be called out
meanwhile we are going to ignore every
every aspect of decision-making that
results in inequality rather than
inequity that's the goal here
because the goal in the end is not to
make lives better for anybody the goal
is simply to tear down the system and
build something magical and new and
utopian in its wake we're gonna get to
more of this in one second first is the
tear down phase of this particular
project you got to tear down the rotten
old infrastructure in order to build
something new and the tear down phase is
exceedingly ugly because guess what
you're tearing down a healthy body
politic and you're replacing it with
nothing good we're gonna get to that in
one second first let's talk about a
great gift you can get for dad this
Father's Day so I'm a watch guy I love
watches I love watches that means I own
some fairly expensive watches it also
means that I own some watches that are
less expensive well if you can't afford
to go out and get your data Rolex for
Father's Day but you want to get him
something that runs beautifully and look
spectacular and looks way above its
price point go out and get your dad I've
been Cheryl one of my favorite sponsors
has been Cheryl watches it's a watch I
love to
we're and they're having an early
Father's Day sale my listeners already
know and Cheryl creates the most
incredible looking watches at an
unbelievable price point again you're
not gonna have to go and spend thousands
of dollars
these are watches that look great well
under 200 bucks there's no better gift
for a father husband grandfather you
name it than giving them the gift of
time with VIN Cheryl watch I've given
them to both my parents actually for my
mom and my dad my wife wears a VIN
Cheryl I've given it to in-laws as well
go check out their watches at VIN Cheryl
watches calm slash at Shapiro Finch
arrow offers free shipping 30-day
returns guarantees your watch for two
years that is why they have over 21,000
five-star reviews you won't find a
better maid watch for this price
anywhere else it's a watch that is
stylish and bold and built to last under
200 bucks they also can engrave on the
back so you can actually engrave a
message to your dad for Father's Day
take advantage of their sale right now
get up to 20% off everything on their
website none of the new items are
off-limits they have brand-new watch
collections you need to see for yourself
online right now is it VIN Cheryl
watches comm slash capiro when you
purchase the discount is automatically
applied at checkout so again go shop
pinch arrow right now the deal is really
good and again this is a great watch for
Dad go to VI n CER o watches comm slash
Schapiro don't pay full price on these
beautiful timepieces get up to 20% off
right now it's a buy you won't regret
inter dad is really going to appreciate
alright we're gonna get to the
cancellation of all the things and the
bullying of all the corporations and the
Assumption by every area of American
life that you must bow the knee or they
will come after you next
which by the way is no guarantee just as
if somebody is blackmailing you you see
this in every movie someone blackmailed
somebody with a piece of information to
say how do I know you won't release it
later they say you don't correct correct
okay that all this is going to be held
over the heads of the American people
consistently we're gonna get to more of
this in just one second this year has
been an unbelievably up-and-down frankly
awful year but incredibly busy news
stuff that you need to keep track of and
the media are lying to you on a routine
basis it's like all the time which is
why so many Americans think things like
the police are systemically racist and
mistreating black people on a vast scale
and endangering their lives that's
because the media lie to you all the
time
when you can't get the real story you
have to go outside the narrative and
actually get the hard facts this is why
you should go get a readers past today
from daily wire calm you'll get access
to exclusive op-eds from us your podcast
host as well as guest writers in depth
analysis from our daily wire reporters
on top of our regular breaking news I
have a piece out today about two
conflicting messages that we are hearing
right now all the mess
from you must speak out too and silences
violence to shut up you're saying the
wrong thing this membership tier is
already a bargain at 3 bucks a month if
you join today you get your first month
for 99 cents you also get access to our
mobile app you'll receive push
notifications for breaking news and
special content and you can join the
community of daily wear members who are
actively commenting and discussing our
content with each other that's mobile ad
free access to all of the daily wear
news exclusive op-eds all of our
podcasts on a mobile app all for the low
price of one dollar best of all your
dollars are getting you the news you
need without the left to spin head on
over to daily wear comm slash subscribe
it join today also as I've been
mentioning I have a book coming out July
21st it's actually really important it's
a very important book I really puts my
own work this way it's hidden I think
it's an incredibly important book I
wrote it back in December in January
when it felt like the country was
starting to come apart at the seams the
pandemic hit and I was like well maybe
it's not relevant anymore because it
seems like we're all on the same page
obviously not the book is what is
happening right now the book is about
the attempt by so many people in the
media in in academia in the political
sphere and many of your neighbors to
divide us along racial and class lines
to destroy America's common philosophy
that says that all men are created equal
under the law and to destroy our common
heritage rights because those rights are
apparently racist if you express
yourself in a way they don't like and
apparently the rights of free speech
must be curbed the rights of free
assembly must be curbed unless they are
protesting for the right things they're
trying to cut down our common history
and suggest that we don't have a common
history the history of America is just
an exploitation and evil they're doing
all of this to dis unify the country and
militarized groups against one another
it's destroying a country my book isn't
just about in a description of this it's
about why it's wrong how you rebut the
arguments is how to destroy America in
three easy steps how to destroy America
in three easy steps you're watching it
happen right now and really in the end
my book is about how to save America by
rebuttals arguments and fighting back
against this particularly ugly narrative
how to destroy America in three easy
steps it comes out July 21st you should
pre-order it right now and go check it
out right now at amazon.com or anywhere
else you get books you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so all the things are canceled as I
mentioned if you're a person who is
starting at Yale and when you were
fifteen you put up a racially ignorant
post then we'll tear you down if you're
LeBron James by the way and last year
you put up a fully on systemic post then
you're fine but if you're a Yale
University freshman Yale University will
then reconsider whether they should
admit you to the University remember
they did the same thing to Kyle Kashyap
when it came out that in private text
you use the n-word when he was 16 years
old and so his admission to Harvard
University was rescinded and he was
outed of course because he had the wrong
politics on gun control and we've seen
everything is now canceled all the
things are canceled so for example we
now know that all entertainment with
cops is going to be cancelled which is
really exciting stuff according to
Deadline Hollywood cops has now been
cancelled by paramount network by the
way the first show to actually focus in
on body cam footage right cops if you
like body cams and you let you know what
the cops are doing cops is that show
cops is a body cam show and by the way I
understand that the media only want to
cover it when the cops do something
wrong there are three hundred seventy
five million interactions between the
cops and citizens in the United States
every year you don't hear about nearly
any of them why because most of them are
the cops doing their job and doing it
properly that doesn't mean that there
aren't bad and stupid cops it doesn't
mean there aren't racist cops but to say
that you cannot air entertainment that
puts you on the same side as law
enforcement is patently insane and makes
the world a worse place because if now
you are suggesting that think like what
do you think the consequences of this
are when you say that the cops are
systemically racist in their targeting
black Americans now you're a black
American you get pulled over by the cops
your immediate suspicion is the reason
that you are being pulled over is not
because you were speeding or not because
there is a reasonable suspicion because
the cops hate black people might that
change your attitude on how you deal
with the police might that mean that a
lot more seventeen year olds who are
pulled over by the police act in ways
that are likely to endanger them and
would endanger anyone if anybody acted
that way if you want to foster better
relations between the police and
communities of color then perhaps you
actually might want to exacerbate the
message that the police care about them
that the police want to help people
instead we're gonna pull down all
entertainment that suggests that cops
are good so Deadline Hollywood
deadline.com reports that cops is
six-year run on paramount network has
come to an end it was pulled last week
in the aftermath of Georgia Floyd's
death a paramount Network spokesperson
said cops is not on the Paramount
Network we don't have any current or
future plans for it to return the
long-running cops from the
on Fox in 1989 the air for 25 seasons by
the way note I wrote a book called
primetime propaganda I interviewed the
guy who created cops you know he told me
he told me that when they selected
footage for cops they deliberately went
out of their way to under sampled
suspects who were black and Hispanic he
told me this openly I have it on tape he
suggested that they went directly to the
footage and then they over sampled white
suspects because they did not want to
forward the perception that too many
black and Hispanic people were
committing crimes that's the show that
just got pulled down from paramount
Network meanwhile a A&E pulled last
weekend's episodes if it's hit
docu-series live PD because obviously if
you cover the police in any good way
that's really bad it must be pulled down
HBO max meanwhile pulled down one of the
great movies of all time Gone with the
Wind
Gone with the Wind when all the Oscars
it was the highest-grossing film of all
time when it came out it is of course a
classic it also resulted in the first
Academy Award win by a black woman
Hattie McDaniel had a McDaniel gave us
she by the way today is her is her
birthday in 1893 she's been wiped away
from history she no longer matters
because after all we got to get rid of
Gone with the Wind because it pushes
images about slavery that we don't like
today so instead of just watching the
movie and saying this is inaccurate
about slavery and it romanticized
slavery and that's bad but the movie
also has something to say about
resilience in the face of pain from
people like Hattie McDaniels and
resilience in the face of pain from the
other characters in the story instead of
doing that we're just gonna pull it down
we have to erase history we're gonna
Stalin eyes history the guy who's
standing next to Stalin on the bridge
just disappeared he's gone no no he
never happened so gone with the wind has
been disappeared into the memory hole so
is Hattie McDaniels who in 1939 talked
about what a historic moment it was that
you won an Academy Award Academy of
Motion Picture Arts & Science
fellow members of the motion picture
industry and honored guests this is one
of the happiest moments of my life and I
want to thank each one of you who had a
part in selecting me for one of the
awards for your kindness it has made me
feel very very humble and I shall always
hold it as a beacon for anything that I
may be able to do in the future I
sincerely hope I shall always be a
credit to my race and to the motion
picture industry my heart is too full to
tell you just hi
for you and may I say thank you
obviously that that's very bad we can't
have any of that and none of that
let's pull down gone with win hvl max
said that gone with wind is quite a
product of its time and to pick some of
the ethnic and racial prejudices that
have unfortunately been commonplace in
American society yes and it turns out
that everything is a product of its time
all the things are products of their
time that is a truth okay and you can
discuss those things that's okay
you pulled down the movie entirely you
pulled down the movie entirely and by
the way are you alright like are we
going to discuss movies like Spike Lee's
movies that very often to pick Jewish
people in the worst possible light as a
product of their time no we can't see
that then because Spike Lee's a good guy
right now that's the way that this works
meanwhile Gerald Baker who is a Wall
Street Journal editor he has now been
moved to the opinion Department he
wasn't editor at large now he's been
moved to the opinion Department why
because staff members of The Wall Street
Journal sends a letter to newsroom
leaders on Monday accusing the paper's
former editor-in-chief Gerald Gerard
Baker who's been an editor at large
since 2018 of violating rules that apply
to those who work on the news side the
letter from the board of the
independence Association of publishers
employees the union that represents
journal staff members according to the
New York Times criticized a column by
mr. Baker on race an accused him of
tweeting in a way that went against the
paper's of social media policy what did
he do wrong well he wrote a column over
the weekend it was a good column in
which he talked about the fact that
people distort the reality of hate crime
in America he described the murder of
Avatar berry the black man shot while
jogging in Georgia after being pursued
by white men and he made the argument
that black people commit more hate
crimes than white people according to
the ia PA well no he actually didn't he
actually he pointed out that black
Americans kill more white Americans on a
percentage basis than white Americans
kill black Americans by the way it is
not close it is not a close statistic if
you're talking about cross racial
killings black Americans if you adjust
for population until far more I think on
an absolute basis to kill far more white
Americans than white Americans go black
Americans that's just a simple fact he
didn't make the case that those were all
hate crimes by the way but then they
they're very angry at his column so he
asked me moved that's the way all of
this works by the way it now turns out
that how how bad is the is the purge the
purge is so bad that if you're white
post something on social media you will
lose your job your wife
NBC News reporting the LA Galaxy said it
has released Serbian soccer star
Alexander khatai on Friday after his
wife
teeka Thai shared a series of racist and
violent social media posts in response
to the George Floyd protests occurring
around the country the Major League
Soccer Club met with khatai on Thursday
after it was made aware of two of his
wife's Instagram posts she shared the
day before after fans protested outside
the LA Galaxy Stadium the club announced
in a one-sentence statement it would
drop khatai from its roster his wife
posted a thing and he lost his job by
the way the thing she posted is yucky
and it's violent it's not actually
racist if you actually look at what she
posted she she posted stuff again that
is that is yucky and violent and she was
labeling protesters thing like she said
disgusting cattle about protesters that
doesn't mean that all the protesters are
black or not if you'd percentage with
protesters or white should she say
anything like that of course not it's
gross she should apologize should her
husband lose his job sure her husband
lose his job her husband we are now
coming for the extended family of people
who post bad things on social media
that's the way this is going to work
it's just amazing meanwhile good news
guys science has shut down so stem is
now the STEM fields so that would be the
science technology engineering math we
are going to shut down the STEM fields
and nature magazine which is the leading
leading magazine in science they say
nature will be joining shut down stem
shut down academia hashtag strike for
black lives will be educating ourselves
in defining actions we can take to help
eradicate anti black racism in academia
and stem shut down stem please join us
hey here's where we get into the actual
results of the bullying and that is you
will repent you will atone you will bend
the knee you will assume that you are a
part of the problem even if there's no
evidence there part of the problem you
know how many affirmative action
programs exist in STEM fields all around
the United States seeking desperately
black employees to join there's a lack
of applicants this is true go to every
major university and ask them if there
are enough applicants who are qualified
and the answer is no do you really think
that engineering programs are
deliberately saying to black people you
cannot enter this engineering program in
fact one of the big problems when it
comes to the earnings potential for
black college graduates versus white
college graduates is how many people go
into the so call
soft studies the liberal arts as opposed
to going into majors that are likely to
earn you a lot of money but stem is
shutting down in nature is is promoting
this nonsense black academic and black
stem professionals are hurting because
they exist in and are attacked by
institutional and system and systemic
racism these are scientists how about
some stats like seriously how about some
stats instead is just a bunch of our
goal our goal it's a bunch of vague
social justice argA Barga black people
is according to shut down stem black
people have been tirelessly working for
change alongside their indigenous and
people of color allies for black
academics and stem professionals shut
down academia shut down stem is a time
to prioritize their needs whether that
is to rest reflect or to act without
incurring additional cumulative
disadvantage aa cumulative disadvantage
now that's that's what's been happening
here I love this they also acknowledge
they say shut down stem and same with
the broad research community who's not
directly participating in any Kovan
nineteen so if you're done Kovac
nineteen then you don't have to shut it
down but what make no mistake the
scientific community is now engaging in
a religious Sabbath because the religion
of woke ism is more important like okay
I understand the religion needs a
Sabbath every religion needs a Sabbath
that's exciting stuff
by the way arts groups are being shut
down as well according to the New York
Times after the nelson-atkins Museum of
Art in Kansas City Missouri allowed the
police to use its property to stage a
response to a protest over George
Floyd's death its director asked the
police to gather elsewhere it issued a
public apology because they allowed the
police to stage a response to a protest
over Floyd's death when the Getty Museum
was criticized for putting out a vague
social media post calling for equity and
fairness that failed to mention Floyd
its chief executive pledged to do better
the San Francisco Museum of Modern Art
was was had to issue language of
contrition we can do better
after first posting an Instagram post
about how about from from an artist
named Glenn Ligon who is black so arts
organizations are now being held to the
fire arts organizations can you think of
more liberal people than arts
organizations across the United States
they do not exist in New York off
Broadway in Brooklyn theaters as well as
the Brooklyn Museum and MoMA have
offered restroom access to protesters
theaters in cities like Oakland
California Austin and Washington have
done the same the Smithsonian National
Museum of african-american history and
culture created an online portal for
discussion about race the Walker Art
Center
Minneapolis announced it would no longer
contract the services of the local PD
for events until the law enforcement
agency quote implements meaningful
change how stupid has all of this become
has become so stupid that gushers the
candy put out a statement about social
justice and racial justice in the United
States because you don't want to be the
last person you don't wanna be the first
person to sit down when the stunts when
Stalin is speaking a famous story from
Gulag Archipelago
bye-bye Solzhenitsyn and my friend Matt
Walsh colleague over daily wire has
cited very very famous story in which
there is a group of Soviet of Soviet
citizens who were present at a Stalin
speech and after he stopped speaking
everybody stood and applauded and then
they all looked around and realized I
can't be the first person to sit down
for this it's a standing ovation I can't
be the first person to sit down and this
thing went on for minutes and minutes
and minutes and minutes and then finally
somebody sat down and then when somebody
sat down everybody sat down and the
first person who sat down was arrested
and sent to the gulag right because
that's the way this works so now all
corporations will be gulag if you are
the first person to sit down during the
during the Maoist struggle sessions so
gushers has to issue a state you know
until gushers and fruit by the foot
issued a statement about white supremacy
I was really under the impression now
this corn syrup based snack for children
that was really under the impression
that they were very much in favor of
them of the murder of black men until
gushers put out a statement they put out
a statement saying gushers wouldn't be
gushers without the black community and
your voices we're working with fruit by
the foot on creating space to amplify
that we see you we stand with you they
say we are devastated by the murders of
George Floyd Brianna Taylor Raman our
Barry and countless others who have been
killed we stand with those fighting for
justice it's important that our actions
match our words more to come we'll have
a long way to go in the fight against
racism for systemic change slow clap for
gushers slow clap for gutters five
seconds ago the entire social justice
warrior movement was laughing at Madonna
for putting up a tape of her son dancing
to Michael Jackson and now the way that
this works is that everyone is expected
to dance to Michael Jackson to virtue
signal to everybody how they feel about
all of this stuff and if you are the
first person to sit down you will pay
the price you will pay the price if you
think by the way that any of this is is
likely to achieve anything like a
lasting change the answer is no it's
likely to achieve
really negative bad divisive backlash
which will be bad because again we
should all be unified on this stuff this
is not hard stuff meanwhile there are
there real-world ramifications for all
of this stuff the real world's
ramifications to the virtue signalling
namely and when the virtue signalling
becomes material and you decide to turn
the virtue signaling into attacking the
police and the police walk away so
that's what's been going on right now so
what the the Democratic Party and the
media have decided that the real bad
guys here are the cops the real bad guys
are the cops who have stood between
American citizens and property
destruction and violence and death and
the community is the most need more
policing our communities that experience
high crime simple fact in the matter I
think it's hilarious to watch as the
media try to treat cams in New Jersey as
an example of a city that did away with
its Police Department and has succeeded
they did away with their local PD they
substituted the County PD they doubled
the number of officers and they made the
police force less racially diverse it
made it less reflective of the community
you want to know why crime went down in
Camden because they took the police
force from 250 to 411 that's why the
crime went down in Camden so don't tell
me you defunded the police when all you
did was actually double the size of the
police force but this is what Democrats
are trying to do is they want to have it
both ways it's it's it's really funny to
watch them in saying things like defund
the police do you fund the police and
then when they're asked about they go we
don't mean be fun the police guys I mean
we obviously mean is more funding for
mental health services okay so why are
you saying to fund the police and the
answer is you're saying to fund the
police because what you actually want is
for the radicals to believe that you're
on their side and at the same time you
don't want to do anything that actually
is gonna undermine safety in your city
so you're a bunch of damn hypocrites
by the way you see this most clearly in
Los Angeles where LA City Council
President Nury Martinez was filing a
motion seeking the 150 million dollar
cut from the LAPD budget meanwhile shed
in LAPD units standing watch outside her
home providing her family with a private
security detail since April paid for by
taxpayers it's in other words defund the
police but not the ones outside my house
guys I need the ones outside my house
all the same people shouting defunding
the police do you fund the police in the
streets those are the same people who
are calling the cops
the minute that there is a crime
committed against them
detective Jamie McBride who serves as
director of the LA Police Protective
League he said it's kind of ironic
here she is demanding 150 million
dollars be reallocated from the police
budget but she has security at her house
by the LAPD this is absurd McBride says
we're taking one unit away from the
equation if a citizen calls 911 there
are less units on the streets respond to
that 911 call the minute that she was
asked about this by the way the police
detail went away now meanwhile you have
the gas lighting right it's all the
police the police are the bad guys
so the predictable after effect if
you're making the case that all
Americans are systemically racist and
that the police are the bleeding edge of
America's systemic racism then you have
to say the police are the bad guys now
here's the problem if you say the police
are the bad guys you know what they're
gonna do they're going to leave so all
the politicians aren't signaling this
you got Bill DeBlasio who is just a
derivative idiot I see he's derivative
cuz he doesn't have even his own bad
ideas he steals other people's bad ideas
and then he decides he's going to
magnify them so yesterday bill de blasio
idiot communist groundhog murderer giant
weird man he announced the new york city
would paint black lives matter on all of
its intersections cuz you know what it
solved the problem in DC didn't it it
paints it black lives matter on the on
the street in DC mayor Bowser all
violence in DC has been solved guys it's
really really exciting stuff and so he's
like you know what if we paint our
streets but we'll do it like every
street and we'll rename streets by the
way this worked beautifully in LA in LA
they they rename South Central Los
Angeles is a heavily black area it had
significant levels of crime in the
aftermath of the Rodney King riots the
City Council of LA decided to rename
South Central Los Angeles to South Los
Angeles
boom all crime solved in South Central
Los Angeles except for renaming things
doesn't change anything
and painting giant slogans on the street
doesn't change anything here was Bill de
Blasio not changing anything but virtue
signaling for the wool crew and the
proposal put on table was to name
streets in each borough and to paint the
words on the streets of this city in
each borough at a crucial location one
of which will be here near City Hall but
what will be clear the street name and
on the streets of our city is that
message that now this city must fully
fully deeply feel and this nation must
as well that black lives matter and the
best way to message that is by painting
that on the streets wow just amazing may
I remem
when when Seattle solved all of its
problems by painting rainbow flags on
the streets also an amazing display of
tolerance University that fixed all the
problems just just paint paint can do
magic paint is magical
who knew kneeling salts kovat and paint
solves racism well done everybody
meanwhile james Clyburn democrat from
south carolina he suggested that the
only violence he's been seeing is from
police officers which is um
controversial to say the least
I mean last night in Seattle ante fo
protesters literally broke into the
mayor's office Jenny Turner turkin Jenny
Durkin is the mayor in Seattle and Jenny
Durkin is a far left Democrat and antiva
literally broke into her offices and
then just sit outside demanding that she
quit with Councilwoman Shama Sawant the
open socialist egging it on violence did
not stop in Portland it has not stopped
in Seattle in fact wherever it's
tolerated is bloomed but here's james
Clyburn suggesting the only violence
she's been seeing is from the cops which
is just high-level gaslighting here from
james Clyburn that's the president's
game insulting people that's not our
game that's the president's game the
only time I saw violence in Washington
DC was those horseback riders driving
people off the street that's when I saw
that to me is his game that's not our
game and we will not play his game yeah
by the way there are absolutely credible
reports and video of protesters I think
here he's speaking of president from
clearing that protest or Secret Service
clearing that protesting it was a bad
optical move but there's video from that
rally people throwing things at cops and
etcetera etc meanwhile Kamala Harris who
was a cos a narc right I mean Kamala
Harris was the AG of the state of
California and she was most famous for
threatening parents of truants with jail
time and here she is saying that the
police are bad she says it's outdated to
think that more police create more
safety which is bolide by every single
fact ever discovered ever removing
police from a community do not create
more safety and if you believe they do
it's because you are a liar she is a
liar
she's a liar Kamala Harris may be vice
presidential candidate Kamala Harris her
she has absolutely
it's outdated to think more police
create more safety except that as soon
as we removed the police last week then
major cities across America to be shut
down in 6 p.m. in Beverly Hills had to
be curfew to 1 p.m.
that's the cops here's Connell Harris
the status quo has been to determine and
create policy around the idea that more
police equals more safety and that's
just wrong you know what creates greater
safety funding our public schools but it
is old thinking it is outdated and is
actually wrong and and backward to think
that more police officers will create
more safety this is insane it's patently
insane obviously it's not true and by
the way you know who knows it's not true
Joe Biden who's basically said that he
is going to expand police budgets if you
want a quash crime you need more cops if
we it's amazing I mean I've been amused
watching the tweets of people who are
saying defund the police so people like
ok so who'll respond to the murder calls
people like you know what we need we
need more Planned Parenthood clinics
like well that's that's a hell of a
statement then what's gonna solve crime
as abortion and that seems kind of
eugenic and racist to me but in any case
the this is the UI that is being told
Trevor Noah did the same thing if you
invest in communities you don't need to
invest in the police yes that's clearly
what's been missing is federal
investment in low-income communities we
haven't done that for the last 60 years
we haven't invested five trillion
dollars in welfare programs ranging from
federal housing projects to food stamps
to unemployment we haven't done any of
that we haven't fed 5 trillion dollars
to achieve a larger racial wealth gap in
the United States than we had in 1965
clearly if we just pour money into into
inner-city communities they will bloom
like the deserts of Judea or
alternatively they won't change a damn
thing because the problem there actually
isn't a lack of money the problem there
is a lack of Public Safety the problem
there is a lack of people being able to
graduate high school the problems that
run a lot deeper than just toss money at
the problem and here's Trevor Noah
saying you don't need cops if you throw
money at people Los Angeles has
announced but they will be taking money
away from the LAPD and putting it into
programs like education and please don't
get it wrong this is not a spite thing
I've seen so many conversations where
people seem like they're punishing the
police no studies have shown
you invest in people when you invest in
communities you don't need to invest in
the police it makes sense prevention is
always better than a cure
especially when the killer kills black
people yeah many the cure kills black
people
no the cure saves black people you know
many black lads were saved in New York
City over baseline by by broken windows
policing literally thousands of black
lads were saved in New York City because
of broken windows policing the cure is
not midnight basketball to crime that
does not solve crime the cure is not
food stamp programs we've tried all of
this and has failed the only thing that
has ever been shown to lower crime rates
ever is additional law enforcement in
high crime communities it's the only
thing literally that's all now there are
things that we can do to alleviate the
burden on law enforcement right we can
make it so that mental illness is
treated by actual mental illness
professionals as opposed to the first
call being 9-1-1 that's a good thing i
back it but if the idea is that you
remove the cops and suddenly things get
safer I urge Trevor Noah to remove his
entire security detail and see if things
get better for him personally
I encourage Comedy Central to remove
their entire private security detail and
see how things go and publicly announce
it but really let's see how it goes for
you I encourage all the people who are
in favor of gun control and believe that
guns make America less safe and that
self-defense is not a thing I encourage
them to out put signs on their lawn
today saying this is a gun free home and
see how it goes for you is the law it's
so stupid so New York's police union had
he came out yesterday and impassion
fascist you need to stop treating us
like racists and thugs or the people who
are standing between human beings who
are being victimized and their
victimizers and you're treating us like
we're the problem is the head of the
Police Benevolent Association in New
York stop treating us like animals and
thugs and start treating us with some
respect
that's what we're here today to say
we've been left out of the conversation
we've been vilified it's disgusting it's
disgusting trying to make us embarrassed
of our profession 375 million
interactions overwhelmingly
overwhelmingly positive okay but he's a
bad guy
he's the bad guy meanwhile what is the
actual reparative what is the actual
reparative policy the people are pushing
their parent policy people are pushing
is move the police off the streets which
is gonna end with more dead black people
because in any area where you have a
disproportionate amount of murder more
people will die if you remove the cops
it is simply that simple there are real
ramifications to all of this social
justice warrior warrior posturing and
bullcrap and you're not making the
country better by purging people for bad
old tweets and you're certainly not
making the country better by forcing
corporations to bend the knee in order
to virtue signal all you're doing is
driving division in an area where we
should all be on the same side and
you're certainly not making the country
better by going after the cops and
suggesting that anyone who speaks of
cops positively is by nature a racist
you ready for a giant exodus of police
officers from forces you ready to make
it impossible for anybody to join the
police force get ready gang because
reality hits you hard bro as a famous
man once said alrighty we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise we will see
you here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel why douse key technical
producer Austin Stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam
SIA vets audio is mixed by Mike or Amina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2020
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]